addio a qualcuno di e benvenuti solide
stories allora oggi andremo a vedere
insieme altri video di trucchetti molto
strani e particolari
e da un po di giorni che continua a
vedere questa thumbnail ovunque su
youtube
mi ha colpito particolarmente
l'ho visto tra l'altro in trending su
youtube america e anche in training su
youtube italia qua e non è non si
capisce molto bene cosa sta succedendo
in questa thumbnail in pratica si vede
il palmo di una mano suppongo che sia il
palmo di una mano per io vedo il palmo
di una mano e poi un bicchiere forse sta
tirando via io spero che non sia un
verme dentro la mano almeno per me un
verme che è entrato dentro una mano però
splinter vuol dire scheggia quindi è da
tutti i giorni da quando è spuntato
fuori questa tua mail che mi chiedo ma
che cavolo è però non ho voluto cliccare
perché voglio che commentiamo assieme
quello che succede
visto che vi piacciono tantissimo questi
video in cui commentiamo e reagiamo
queste cose isole scheggia perché c'è un
punto interrogativo scheggia ho quindi
lascio interpretar lascia intendere uno
o qualcos'altro bombe mentre di dentro
la bella comunque la7 un like se volete
vedere altre reazioni e commentari
assieme e iniziamo subito allora ecco
qua
iniziamo subito con quel trucchetto per
fortuna in genere lo mettono tipo alla
fine
adobe comunque sono compilation di
questi trucchetti un po particolari
comunque vediamo finalmente che cosa
succede a questa mano dice coach a
splinter quindi ripreso ma scherzo gli
dice hai una scheggia nella mano ma
quella non mi sembrava proprio una
scheggia comunque vediamo cosa fa
c'è però uno scherzo cosa c'è io vado un
lp tutti i propri giorni mi chiedevo
cosa forte era una scheggia io pensavo
fosse un verme oppure un brufolo gigante
che stanno facendo tutto il pool e
scusate ma un pò schifo
cosa farà cosa era una che ora sono
quell'ora il trucchetto di mettere un
bicchiere la spira tipo l'attira via
secondo me non fa nulla era già fuori
così vabbè non lo so ho qua allora che
cos'altro succederà scusa stava giocando
con una tigre peluche diventato gli ho
fatto dei grassi di pigra della savana
video disdette di alle tigri e poi l'ho
visto l'evoluzione di atti dice come
fatti per dare sì che non cada la benda
lo mette attorno al polo bagnati piedi
ma questo cosa già sentita con l'acqua
calda
ecco perché ci sono le verdure congelate
in testa
che strana alto ai piedi e freddo in
testa io a me avevano detto in pratica
secondo me purtroppo viene spesso mal di
testa me m'hanno detto di mettere i
piedi nell'acqua fredda
così tutto il calore e il sangue che ha
in testa va direttamente i piedi per
riscaldarle e dovrebbe passare il mal di
testa non ho mai provato se avete mai
provato si sta pensando che ha ragione
perché questo fa un po grande rari
infatti i nodi caldi forse più comodo
però avere i piedi caldi nella testa
fresca allora se cadi e ti fai male anzi
a a
addio dice che puoi smettere di
sanguinare mettendoci sopra
dell'alluminio noi
elio e ferocia questo componente siccome
nel giro di un mese dal min jung florid
se lo metti soprattutto di sanguinario
paura che bruci
tanti però l'alluminio ovvero che la
sanguigna ma che quando dal barbiere
secondo fare la barba usano questi
pezzettini qui per farti se sei un
piccolo dall'inazione ma fa bene alla
pelle non è che magari fa male non lo so
bruciare poco poco soltanto dai fatti di
sabari se avete mai provato a mettere
deodorante invece che nella vostra
scelta per il vostro sito un livido sono
tutti scioccati
se ti fai male però come aceto di mele
aceto di mele poi porta all insalata di
pomodori 3 4 ore
non lo so mai provato un taglietto
cerotto è andato io no a in modo tale
che rimanga questo è veramente utile
figo non cala subito
bravi bravi questo è
un progetto molto intelligente che
potremo addio a qualcuno se qualcuno ti
gratis coda dietro ben addio
confermi penso proprio che sia
incredibile una bella testata ma quando
sono in giro 8 ore poi con i tacchi
perché non serviranno mai però a
bellavista questa mia preferita un bel
morso gli spacchi un braccio sto
pensando questo tipo poveretto che
ovviamente la traccia violente sono
degli attori questi per dimostrazione
questo paese ha preso un sacco di botte
se hai un orecchio tappato a queste sono
le candele sono statici niente per le
ore io non mettetevi una candela
dell'orecchio queste le vendono
dovrebbero in farmacia e tipo ti
stappano l'orecchio però a volte non
funzionano insomma dipende riazzera
tutto
ecco a voi tubo non era solo ricchiuto
fater orecchio struie
io sono entrata nate un po esagerati
allora attirato gli ho tirato un pugno
in faccia per sbaglio alcol e sapone
serviamo per i piatti dentro una bustino
forse per far guarire libido per
congelarlo forza e poi lo puoi usare
tipo ma perché sapone per piatti capita
che li vide mai la stessa un altro
consigli per il mal di testa vediamo
mordi normativa ma dai
dice che aiuta a rilassare i muscoli
delle mascelle tutti noi dobbiamo
provare questa proposta ancora
proviamolo già passato castità
incredibile miracoloso questa sarà la
zanzara questa ci può essere un limone
chiodi di garofano ha infatti questa
misura che vendono anche le candele dove
li troviamo i che delineano compriamoli
tutti i limiti a fianco al letto con
bene dopo l'oro di piace questo
trucchetto perché anche naturale
potete usare questi spray fanno male i
denti by dal dentista
no usa del sale e acqua
e chissà che sapore delizioso matttino
limiti ed esce così per dovrebbe proprio
letto funzionare perché tipo un
conservante lo zio coprire quindi se
fini se sei nella calca tra l'altro è
pericolosissimo trovarsi in queste
situazioni potresti davvero essere
schiacciato non coprire la testa con le
mani e non mettere le ginocchia che
comprano il tuo stomaco pancia proprio
grazie alla gamba di qualcuno è
tirati su iraq su
spero che poi quello con lo butti giù lo
stand terremoto
oddio sono però a volte terribili questi
trucchetti non nasconderti direttamente
ai terribili nel senso per situazioni
terribili termopili trucchetti non
nasconderti direttamente sotto il tavolo
io pensavo che si dovesse fare così
ti devi nascondere vicino ai le gambe
alle gambe del tavolo così è meno
probabile che si sfondi gli abiti
tagliati infiltrano il fumo per
respirare l'ente in pratica si trovino e
mezzo di un incendio di ospizio do mai
nessuno ed è pieno di fumo per
continuare a respirare bevi respira
attraverso abiti bagnati per che fissano
al fumo c'è scritto che se non hai abiti
bagnati e di b b
va bene uguale di fare la fip iscritti
mentre alle ore l'alcol in una ferita
aperta che brucia da morire tra l'altro
un assorbente ammette il cotone e dello
scotch trail scosse isolana striscia
laureate peggio beh forse comunque medio
per farla guarire di nuovo fumo ed è
perché così almeno respiri aria pulita
cioè pulita meno meno fumo allora oddio
ma la situazione terribile
stai negando di paillettes ariota di
rubare vestiti lascia le gare addio ma
allegato i pantaloni per stare in fare
aria la tua fano questa cosa dire se non
c'è l'acqua
[Musica]
una busta data a trasformi in una socia
figo la cuffietta per la piscina che
fastidio iodio bagno e ti fai un bel
dialetto l'intesa addirittura
magicamente defilata saranno buttava in
testa c'è la tua maschera si inventa
sempre ma anche senza forse utilizza il
nero dell'accendino per per pulirla si è
poco dentifricio quindi non diventa più
asili
non lo so come un effetto nome e non si
sa fanno più
allora a carinola quindi quando un
meccanica non si ma le ragazze
è questo è un giocatore che conosco pure
ma niente wow
dobbiamo provare a farlo ma se
bellissimo questo anello
cosa nasconde dentro un bigliettino
segreto aprire la porta senza lasciare
impronte digitali
ma con la carta questa è un vecchio
trucchetto quindi è scritto di più qui
sta cancellando con rosso fumetti bello
questo da provare
il bello di limone a questa parola in
sosta ho visto sì se metti poi una
candela questo invece ero con 13 punti
house i per fare gli occhiali 3d per non
fare sbavature forse ala con la tona sì
l'avevo visto per quelli non per fare lo
smalto maps con il vapore figlio bello
questo qua o là water marble manicure
non sono mai riuscita a far la guerra
come si fa con stima ma questa cosa che
bellina però non sono mai riuscito a
farla
nessuna spezza anzi tra l'altro si
sporchi un sacco di dita 15 di usare la
colla e poi questo mondo per l'affetto
però si l'effetto è bellissimo pure lo
zero si tenta una tassa ma questo con la
spugnetta anche questo non sono mai resi
da farlo ammette prima i colori sulla
spugnetta e poi dopo su lunghezze ma che
lo facciamo non riusciva tutto impastato
non so voi siete mai riusciti ma sembra
molto bello si aspetta bello
[Applauso]
e la freccia che è difficilissimo le
geniali non lo so adesso è molto bene
con l'elastico penso che sta un po
storta però una roba ci si prende la
studia stende abiti blender distrutta la
cosa va il palloncino l'abbiamo visto
questo è diventata molle
cosa fa il succo di mela veramente se
con telenovele was funzioni diventa così
chiesto dentro la bottiglia ovviamente
con si entra
una bustina per fare con le bacchette ai
vari questi chiesto comuni da mettere
nella bottiglia bene io casa sembrano
troppo grandi queste razzano quello sì
ma le portate a spicchi qualcosa della
mela si che buona
iamm la mela diventa nera del panino
tutto motion si è nota si scava tolto
della mela e la taglia a fette apple a
ricomponi ma è così non non diventa lei
era capito e non si mischia sia un altro
panino avete già tagliata a dire no e
blu colore o ma perché sto fase del
feeling
niente i punti neri e una fragola per i
minori punti neri si ha messo capone
bollano carboni gelatino per la maschera
nera e questo dovrebbe funzionare
è facile forse questo tipo le maschere
che vendono per i piedi ha scritto che
continueranno ad e spogliarsi per 5 7
giorni
che brutto io sono molto strano un
problema colore o di enorme aiuto hanno
lasci per 5 minuti
ma come gesto barzi incredibile questo
aglio che cosa è successo qua sale
bicarbonato acqua calda a 100 poi fu
morello però chi volesse ha forse per
chiarire l'ascella
caspita a quanto troppo i loro nomi sono
rimasta addio che c'è la forfora come
glitter cipolla in testa allora e alle
imprese era litro che liberalizzi farti
sapere nei commenti quale riesce a carte
di più a me decisamente quello della
scheggia nella mano che ancora vi sembra
un verme o un brufolo fiat è invece
quello del durante ascellare ha messo
sul ginocchio che poi dopo ovviamente
dopo che l'hai messo sul ginocchio
sbucciato alcol sangue dolori metti sono
lasciati
vi lasciamo ora come quattro case
l'innesco cliccare per vedere nelle
nostre reazioni challenge video
divertenti cliccate su quella che
preferite
ciao